welcome to this video playing melo melo
or maybe that's pronounced entirely
differently i don't know from from
greece and we have a check benoni not
check as and checkmate but check as in
the czech republic okay well I normally
play Bishop g2 against that this type of
setup yeah well normally means the very
rare occasion that you actually get the
so bring but it's not so bad it's
usually leading to two very close
positions that are quite quite
interesting to play for strategically
inclined players okay he's preparing a
five my responsible bf4 maybe
immediately okay he's mixing plans hmm
okay maybe I need to need to play before
myself 197 I'm going to play I could
play a 5 also interesting I cuts also
could play a five it's not bad okay this
playing weddings well before now I don't
like but it's not preparing beehive
anymore and this in this type of
position they needed the night to do
that okay so let's play a couple of more
a couple of strengthening moves like a
shrieking h2 when f5 there's always f4
and the position will open up to White's
advantage because I just have better
placed pieces for the opening of the
position Quincy 7 is really a bit of a
strange movie on you know it's it's hard
to to stay put all the time but this is
an untimely opening of the position i'm
pretty sure yes a hard time though okay
um Knight takes I could also take a five
we have all night takes us normal
Wow well that's a bit shocking I thought
95 really is a big threat but he's got
Knight b6 maybe ok but I can take take
one first mascot Knight b6 my practices
maybe maybe maybe playable
the funny movie is before before takes
before maybe c5 Eddie's son this is just
too much too much I need to do the
simple move 95 threatening 96 and let's
see what his response as Knight b6 I'm
taking be five yeah I probably just must
take it i don't see another i don't see
em hmm now be three there's some way to
live probably not i need to take it now
the position is not entirely clear I'm
really surprised that that i'm not i'm
not having more here this at 5am and b5
looks looked really strange to me maybe
after a fight i should have taken and
then F for possible who knows it's
difficult this game be three what about
what about queen bee three how does he
respond to that
nightby to Queen B 5 rupee tool Quincy
form okay he had a response simple one
but damn i have night d 5 now I night is
sick so sorry yeah I need to do that
anyway come on
play now is focused on the idea in seven
Bishop g5 check on maybe 93 to d5 also
yes but I thought I thought after Quincy
to he's not having a good enough I I
thought I thought where why does it go
okay but night f4 is this very dangerous
95 for example yeah this capture cam I
protected be too so I couldn't just take
on btooom
c7 Bishop g5 check is not good well help
it's also nice g6 at some point I came
on let's play that let's play that ok I
now on this this is easy for once
running right into the pin yeah this guy
is really putting up some some stiff
resistance with 1,900 rating right
before we get seven analysis this of
course is very helpful for me chat but
before that you really played the played
well ok is there some way I need to use
their farm why should I just keep keep
the pawn come on it let's just keep the
upon this must be good
check and 95 this was my idea mmm
intending to take on f6 now everything
is active the rock is of course also
hanging okay just look f6 I look yet now
right Queen takes time morning come on
Wow twenties I've got 20 seconds left no
check check
and Kenya six Ruger six
give me six creamy for as much easier
okay check
kingi eight come on let's go here this
must be too much Queen f8 made come on
and Queen f7 check
okay no one I'm up on the clock black
for fence on time I absolutely forgot
the clock only when I was down to 20
seconds I was paying some attention do
that yeah whatever we had what a weird
game again yeah probably i need to
improve him as weird as it sounds when
ff4 is completely completely standard
this reply but it it wasn't clear it
simply wasn't a clear position and
quincy seven is just too strange a move
to to believe that it should be okay for
like maybe I need to take and then f4
maybe something like that yeah but he
can he can play a form you can play your
form I don't have this smooth I I can
play it but it's not not so great and I
need to prepare it and it's not not
clear it's not clear at all maybe maybe
why this is ok here but it's it's just
completely completely crazy position and
here Jim 93 there are many interesting
news this is given us as equal by the
computer yeah this loses not afraid this
is really too much 95 and so on check
yeah there was some some some stronger
chopard it was it was enough why the
White was winning here Wow very
complicated and quite surprising come
out to play that like somebody got with
b5
okay thanks for watching